[Music]
now
unless you've been living under a rock
for the past year you've probably
noticed that
chess has taken twitch by storm
and as with all games there are a wide
variety of channels you can tune into
for starters you've got your world
champions and goats
who make the most big-brained
competition in human history
look like tic-tac-toe oh there's the
queen
there's the knight
and there's mates cool that was closer
than i thought
then of course you've got your actual
streamers esteemed educators who've
found a way to juggle
professional play with guiding scrubs
through the complexities of chess
someone um suggested i perhaps call you
hika roowoo what are your thoughts on
that
i prefer i mean i'm used to i've heard a
lot of french people say my name the
other way so i actually like it i prefer
it that way
so that's better that's better yeah
yeah got it yeah a lot of people saw
that okay all right
and last but certainly not least you've
got your
truly filthy casuals
living breathing pepegas who to their
credit decided to wake up
exchange livestream fails for a game
board and think to themselves
i'm going to use a brain cell today
[Music]
pogba's what why did
this happen i didn't even know what that
what the [ __ ] happened
but there's one streamer who despite
being a high level player
hip with the kids and hellbent on
initiating newcomers
doesn't fit into any of these categories
well
two streamers actually
meet alexandra and andrea botes
aka the botez sisters a pair of
chess fiending firecrackers who've made
it their mission to ensure that the
traditionally stuffy
gatekeepy and all-around elitist game
they love
becomes as popular and accessible as
humanly possible
even though the way they've decided to
do that
hasn't always garnered them support
hikaru has just been really really upset
about the just chatting category thing
and you know hikaru feels strongly about
all of his opinions
and um sometimes goes out of the way to
make them known
so how did the botest sisters become the
most down-to-earth chess mongers on
twitch
in what sense are they democratizing
earth's oldest esports
and why have they gotten flack for it
she's in the car
positioned like a little [ __ ] dog
like this
like she's about to fart in my face i
feel like she was about to
unleash a weapon i mean i had to get
revenge
put your ass down and she's like no no
this is how i prepare myself
okay so first things first who are these
badass board game savants known as the
botesses
let's start with alexandra since she's
the elder a
five-time canadian national girls
champion she worked
tirelessly to win the us girls nationals
at the age of
15 thereby earning herself a four-year
full-ride scholarship to the university
of texas at dallas
the fact that i was able to get a
full-ride scholarship was super
important especially for my parents who
had been
you know prioritizing it for me since i
was in high school
for them they came you know from romania
they were an immigrant family so having
education paid for in the u.s was a huge
deal for them because otherwise
you know we were really worried about
how we'd be able to afford college so
that was a super exciting moment by the
time she was 18
this american-born canadian of romanian
descent had secured herself the title of
woman feed a
master and instead of shipping off back
to her birth city of dallas
opted to study international relations
with a focus on
china at stanford she's back at stanford
but not back to real work or school just
yet
helping us to break down the critical
moments from these world chess
championship games is of course
women's video master alexander botez
anyway in addition to her nutty ass work
ethic
alexandra boasted such an affinity for
chess that
she'd spent much of her life being
hailed as a natural
i started playing chess when i was six
years old my dad taught me
and the way he passed it on to me was a
little bit
trolly so he made a bet with my mom and
he said that i will teach
our six-year-old how to play chess and i
bet she could beat you in two weeks
my mom thought it would be funny so she
took it he taught me you know a couple
trips
tricks i was able to beat her and then i
continued playing and started competing
in national tournaments in canada
now even though alexandra had dabbled
with content creation in the past
it wasn't until 2019 that she decided to
fully commit
to streaming it was completely a hobby
for the first
two years or so i started increasing how
much i would stream
but i only went into it full time after
my startup failed and i was
trying to decide where to go to from
there and even then it was a pretty
risky
choice and by 2020 her channel was
earning
tons of recognition some people even
drew comparisons between her and
beth harmon the precocious pill-popping
protagonist of netflix's chess drama
the queen's gambit a parallel she
definitely had some fun with
i'm not overthinking the fact that it's
okay
it's okay it's me alexandra even
patented her
own signature move the botez gambit
which entails
sacrificing one's queen
for absolutely nothing this is a bad
sack usually you don't want to give a
knight and a bishop for a rook in a pond
which is what i just did but since we're
already up two pawns i'm gonna go
oh my god i just gave my queen for free
the bow test gambit
ladies and gentlemen now part of
alexandra's rise in popularity was
obviously covid and the sort of online
chess renaissance that helped create
from magnus to freaking xqc twitch
helped this
genuinely ancient board game appeal to
zoomers in a
big way so i studied international
relations in college and there's this
concept called black swans
for things that are very unlikely to
happen but also
expected and you cannot expect that to
happen based on previous events
and this is what happened with the chess
boom i was able to grow along with it
and
maybe much more so than other people and
on top of that
i was really the only full-time chess
streamer who is not
a full-time chess player i identify
myself as a content creator not as a
chess player and that is very different
than others but
it was also amidst all of this success
that the channels saw the addition
of baby botas smells like mickey d's
it does these nuts if alexandra was the
quiet
responsible straight-laced sibling who
always seemed like she was doing
everything perfectly andrea brand risk
botes was
at least on the surface pretty much
everything but that
oh i can't believe andrea ate hemorrhoid
cream i didn't
eat it i accidentally ingested it but do
not think for a
second that she was not an absolute
shark
once the pieces were set okay this is a
mistake
now the night the night is misplaced and
now he dropped the pawn this is how you
play chess buddy
boom roasted so what was it that set the
botes apart
well despite being genuinely bonkers at
chess
they were easygoing and approachable by
putting their personalities first
they made themselves engaging and
accessible to literally
anyone who tuned in i never want to just
do
one thing i would be bored out of my
mind and i was starting to get extremely
bored and extremely depressed when i was
just doing 40 50 hours of chest a week
it's just
not stimulating enough for me and i'm
not a professional player where it's
like completely the nuances and it's my
living but there's also a place on
twitch for these personality streamers
who are able to do a lot of different
things and that's the vibe we're going
for while always making sure that the
biggest
and most popular thing that we do is
chess because at the end of the day i do
still want to give back to the chess
community
so of course chess wasn't always the
focus of their stream
sometimes you'd catch them cooking
[Applause]
other times delving into esports
a little jumping jack hell they'd even
go full normie and bang out among us
from time to time
uh i need to see when the kill happens
well in my defense i did see where the
kill happened
by blurring the lines between board
gamers
e-gamers and variety streamers the
botest sisters were able to cater to
virtually
everyone who hung out on twitch whether
you came for the chess
and stayed for the content or vice versa
no one could deny that the botezes were
dank
down to earth and just generally
unceremonious in a way that other more
self-serious streams simply weren't
chess
dirty talk sounds hot though i was
thinking about this last night
flamin buddy what are you
talking about mate
yeah i really like the way she put her
king on h7
look at that king all cornered what a
[ __ ]
the question was at what cost you see
in an effort to grow their channel the
boteses would sometimes list their
stream under twitch's hugely populated
just chatting tap this caught the
attention of super grand
master content creator and all-around
chess
deity hikaru nakamura and
well not in a good way seven to ten
thousand viewers that are not showing up
in the chess directory because bootes
are streaming chats and just chatting
and um
and so what that does i think is that
makes it very hard because when when you
have
advertisers or sponsors looking to
looking to the chess directory and
thinking about say sponsoring pogchamps
too
or other possible events what it does is
the numbers aren't reflective
the numbers aren't actually truly
reflective of the number of people
watching chess
but the bow tests they saw things
differently
in our situation we know that twitch
discoverability is a really huge issue
with the with a platform
and it's hard even if you're making
really good content to get new viewers
and one thing that helps
is if you're on the top of a category so
this is more of a learning what works
best on the platform
um we checked with chess.com before we
did and we said hey our approach is
we're still playing chess we still have
the chess.com logo
everybody knows what this game is it's
going to reach a new audience is it okay
if we do this
needless to say this sparked a bit of a
tiffle between the botezes and tekaru
he felt that by drawing viewers away
from the chess tab
they were doing a disservice to the game
that they all wanted to grow
they felt that the point was just to
grow chess at all costs
hikaru was ranting yesterday about how
he thinks it's important to support each
other and grow the community on twitch
not only his own channel
this is why i exploded because he only
cares if the people he's supporting act
the exact way he wants no it's not the
community it's the community
that hikaru likes that is
very clear and very straight and if you
think
that's fake then you haven't been
watching chess on twitch
so like stop coming in with this
propaganda as if it's the truth
because it's not okay
now in the end hikaru and the sisters
were able to sort things out privately
and any semblance of drama was put to
rest
why because surprise surprise these
chess geniuses are adults behaved as
such
and the botezes came out in an even
better position than before
i actually apologized to hikaru
yesterday because i think
you know whatever happens you sh if your
public personalities it's not something
that you should
talk about on your streams so we talked
it out
we're actually good now and probably
closer than we were before he even gave
me youtube advice
holy smokes we were doing a big public
announcement but
thank you so much oh my god in just
one short year the boteses have somehow
solidified themselves
as one of twitch's most innovative and
original
forces of nature in addition to standing
up the most successful chess stream
ever they've befriended countless
juggernauts
brought huge non-endemic sponsors into
the space
and were among the game's first
influencers to get signed by an esports
org
you cannot plan for and often you cannot
choose when you get that moment but
if you're lucky enough to have it um
then
you have to make sure you make the most
of it so for me i i i was
just in complete disbelief and so so
excited to see it happening
if there's one thing to be learned from
the botez's meteoric rise
it's that there's no such thing as
making something too
accessible they've shown that it doesn't
matter how or where
someone gets into a game when it comes
to bolstering its success
only that someone gets into it that with
just a little savviness and a shitload
of spunk
even something as aged and antiquated as
chess can be born anew
[Applause]
i think chess is the original esport it
hasn't it hasn't been patched since like
the 19th century
the the queen the queen has been op for
a thousand years what are they gonna
nerf the queen i don't know dude
dude honestly though it's [ __ ] like
i like this i i i'm not playing i'm
quitting chess until they nerf the queen
i'm done with it
it's it's it's it's just it's ruining
the game